Speaker 1: Fox News visibly and brazenly continues
to lie about the Twitter bombshell Twitter files
which flopped softer than a wet noodle this
one is going to be. I know that this isn't
going to work as well for people just listening
today because there's a visual component here.
Play along for a moment and then I'll explain it
all to you. I'm going to play a clip for you of
Ted Cruz, Cancun Cruz, senator from Texas,
appearing on Fox News. This was yesterday.
To talk about the Twitter files and if
you're watching. Keep an eye on the screen
and see if you can identify
something weird on the screen.
Let's listen. And then we are going to discuss.
Speaker 2: Look, Jesse, what what Elon Musk has
released is evidence of corruption that goes
to the highest level of government. It goes to
the highest level of the FBI, and it goes to the
highest level of big tech. We've known for a long
time that big tech is censoring conservatives.
But what Elon did here is he just laid naked all
of the lies that the corporate media has told,
because it's clear during the 2020 election,
over and over and over again, the by the Biden
campaign and the DNC would reach out to their
buddies at Twitter and say, hey, we don't like
this. And their response is handled and they
take it down over and over and over again.
And in particular, all of the exchange back
and forth. When the Hunter Biden laptop story
broke, it was evidence that the leadership at
Twitter knew within hours that that that
their ridiculous fake excuse that it was
hacked was a ridiculous, fake excuse to eat.
Speaker 1: Wow. I mean it I don't know that
there's anything true in what Ted Cruz is saying,
but let me call your attention to a couple of
different things. At the start of the segment,
the title at the bottom of the screen that Fox
puts up says Biden White House had direct line to
Twitter censors. Okay, what? Biden White House.
What Biden White House. This all took place in
2020 when Joe Biden was not the president of the
United States. There was no Biden White House.
Now, do you want to write this off as some kind
of technicality? Because it's really not there is
no such entity as the Biden White House unless you
believe in some kind of strange time travel that
Democrats had access to in 2020. Also direct line.
They had an email address. They had an email
address. And as I've said before, if you want
to make the case that a political campaign, not
an administration, that a political campaign,
the Biden campaign should have had to use the
same system I have to use. Right. Like, you know,
on Twitter. We're on Twitter right now. If I don't
like a tweet, I have to click the little thing and
then report tweet. Right. And I got to fill out a
form and do a whole different thing. If you want
to make the case that they should have had to do
that rather than emailing someone at Twitter when
revenge porn of Hunter Biden was posted. I'm
glad to have that conversation with you. Maybe
that's true. Maybe they should have to do the same
thing I have to do rather than email someone. But
that's not really a bombshell. That's a little
issue around the edges. The main story here
is not really a story. This was about content,
nude images of Hunter Biden that he didn't release
that violates Twitter's guidelines about revenge
porn. It's content that was illegal in just about
every state in the United States and I believe
against federal law as well, although I'd have
to refresh my memory on that. Back from the start
of the Hunter Biden story and the entire story,
Biden White House didn't exist. Direct line. It
was an email address. This exposes corruption at
the highest levels. Not really. Maybe they should
have had to use the report tweet function rather
than an email. It flopped. And again, I don't
know if Ted Cruz knows it flopped, but is lying or
doesn't realize that it flopped. Ted Cruz is smart
enough to probably realize that. So I would lean
on he's being dishonest rather than ignorant.
But with Ted Cruz, you never really know.